est-ce qu'on est pas dans une impasse
est-ce que la bataille des retraites en
réalité elle est pas déjà perdue et déjà
terminé moi je crois pas je suis pas sûr
les oppositions sont toujours là
toujours mobilisées il y a deux choses
il y a les oppositions sociales et
politiques sont toujours là social vous
savez depuis je sais pas combien de mois
nous annonce la fin de l'intersyndicale
à l'appel à une grande journée de
mobilisation le 6 et tous les
responsables Laurent Berger compris
préviennent le gouvernement que il ne
faut pas utiliser je ne sais quel
artifice pour faire en sorte que la
propulsion de loi liotte le 8 ne soit
pas voté d'accord donc il y a toujours
une mobilisation forte je vous rappelle
que les décrets ne sont toujours pas
passé que on ne sait pas s'ils arrivent
à passer en septembre donc c'est pour
l'instant elle est pas piquée et moi je
crois que c'est autant d'espoir pour
vous oui je crois que vous savez je fais
partie d'un d'un milieu professionnel
avant d'être élu qui est la voile que de
compétition vous le savez où on dicte
tant que la ligne d'arrivée n'est pas
franchie et bien la course n'est pas
perdue et bien moi j'ai le même point de
vue sur ses doigts parce que elle n'est
pas bonne elle ne règle aucun problème
par rapport au régime des retraites mais
par contre elle faut elle force les
Français à travailler deux ans plus et
c'est une fois de plus sur le monde du
travail à qui qu'on demande de de faire
peser les sacrifices donc pour ces
raisons il faut emmener la bataille
jusqu'au bout et puis on tirera les
conclusions après avant de parler des
conclusions est-ce que vous donnez pas
quand même un peu un l'espoir aux
opposants à cette réforme des retraites
en leur faisant croire que cette réforme
sera abrogée et que ce texte pour aller
jusqu'au bout de reprendre les arguments
du gouvernement là-dessus on entend ça
depuis des jours
si je suis si demain je gouverne ce pays
que je n'ai pas fait passer cette loi
j'ai pas pu la faire passer devant
l'Assemblée parce que j'avais peur
d'être minoritaires que j'applique à
49-3 et que lorsqu'il y a une
proposition loi d'abrogation elle est
passée je dis que si je continue bike il
y a vraiment un problème ça sera vous le
savez bien et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que le gouvernement et la majorité enfin
la majorité les parties les groupes
gouvernementaux hésitent éventuellement
à me saisir sur l'article 40 c'est
qu'ils ont peur de la défaite et s'ils
ont peur de la défaite c'est que ça
vient qu'à Lorraine conséquence
politique si cette loi est battue à
l'Assemblée je ne vois pas comment elle
s'applique de manière normale ça sera
bien pire de ce point de vue là que ce à
quoi par exemple Jacques Chirac a eu
affaire quand il s'est opposé au
CPE excusez-moi avec les programme des
fois
qui ne l'a pas appliqué parce que lui a
compris au moins qu'on ne faisait pas un
moment donné des lois contre tout un
peuple là ce gouvernement est dans cette
situation si l'assemblée votre compte
j'espère j'espère vivement pour la suite
de son quinquennat il ne serait-ce que
ça parce que je vous remarqué que on en
est qu'à un an il reste 4 ans que il
passera il ne passera pas outre le vote
de l'assemblée et puis sinon on verra ça
partira ça partira au cinéma ça revient
à rassembler vous savez qu'il peut y
avoir plusieurs retours pourquoi
pourquoi pas forcément
si le Sénat votre contre
il peut y avoir une deuxième et là d'un
essai puis une troisième lecture donc il
faut du temps c'est très long c'est très
compliqué oui ça peut ne pas être
compliqué vous savez ce qu'ils sont pas
de conclusif aussi c'est l'application
de cette loi voilà parce que moi je
pense que si la pression sociale par
exemple donne une idée si c'est si cette
loi n'est est refusé à l'Assemblée vous
croyez qu'il va se passer quoi au niveau
syndical au niveau social vous croyez
que les ça va pas donner un regain
d'activité de mobilisation moi je le
crois voilà je crois que ce gouvernement
n'en sera de ce point de vue là qu'au
début de ses problèmes et je lui répète
je pense que il ferait bien enfin de
comprendre que sur cette propulsions loi
il est archi minoritaire dans le pays et
qu'il est très certainement minoritaire
à l'Assemblée nationale mais qu'il est
qu'il le laisse vérifier le 8 c'est ça
que je demande d'accord puisqu'il a
l'air de dire que ça ne se réglera rien
c'est pas très grave mais qu'il le
laisse vérifier au moins respirable
mieux
[Musique]